الاخبار المزعجه كاخبار الحروب والكوارث
الطبيعيه تؤثر علينا بشكل كبير لكن يبدو
انا مدى تاثير هذه الاخبار مختلفه بين
الرجال والنساء فعدد النساء التي صرحن
بانهن يعانين من نوم سيء بسبب الاخبار
العالميه السيئه يزيد كثيرا عن عدد الرجال
الذين صرحوا بنفس الامر بحسب استطلاعن
للراي في المانيا
بنسبه 26% من النساء المشاركات فلستطلاع
الذي اجراه احد 1 بول لاننا على نحو سيء
للغايه عند توارد انباء مزوجه حول الاحداث
العالميه مقابله 17% من الرجال فقط كما
زادت النسبه اللائي ذكرنا انه لا يستقرنا
بصوره متكرره علينا من الكوابيس مقارنه
بالرجال وبحسب الدراسات
بتراجع القدره على الاداء وعدم التركيز
بصوره اكبر عند النوم بشكل سيء فعندما
تذهب المراه غضبه الى السرير او متوتره او
تشعر بالقلق عاده ما يكون نومها غير مستقر
وقلقا جيد وهذا ما يؤثر سلبيا على صحتها
على المدى القصير وعلى المدى الطويل
فنوعيه النوم تؤثر على الصحه العامه
المزيد معانا دحجاز
[موسيقى]
في عصري وسائل الاتصال الحديثه التي تعمل
على نشر الاخبار باستمرار تشعر الكثير من
النساء ان الاخبار السيئه منها تحاصرهن
وتؤثره على جودتي نومهان خاصه وان الاخبار
المفرحه والايجابيه غالبا ما تطمر وتحت
اكوام الكوارث الطبيعيه والمفتعله
دراسه السابقه من جامعه مونتريال الكنديه
وجدت ان النساء يتفاعلن مع الاخبار السيئه
بضغط النفسيه اكبر من الرجال
ويتذكرنا الامور السلبيه افضل منهم اذ
بيانات الدراسه وان النساء اللواتي قرانا
الاخبار السلبيه ارتفعت لديهن مستويات
هرمون الاجهاد كما تبين ان النساء والرجال
يتذكرون الاخبار المحايده بالمعدل لنفسه
في حين ان النساء تذكرنا اكثر بمراتين من
الرجال عناوين الاخبار السيئه
فكما يبدو فانا النساء يميلنا الى الشعور
بالمزيد من المشاعر السلبيه
مع الاحداث السلبيه عندما يكونن متعبات في
نهايه يوم طويل بحث في الخبراء لذا فان
الاخبار السيئه في وقت متاخر من زي اللي
بدلا من النوم تعد كارثه في حديثتها فلا
اخبار السيئه تؤثر على النساء اكثر من
الرجال وتضل في ذاكرتهن اكثر من الذكور
لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره
[موسيقى]
سعد صباحك اهلا به بك هل فعلا النساء اكثر
تاثرا بالاخبار السيئه من الرجال هل يعني
ذلك ان النساء اكثر حساسيه والرجال اكثر
بروده كيف نفهمها نفسيا
صباح الخير سهام بدون نادين صباح الخير
على العربيه مشاهدين مستمعين متصفحين
النساء اكثر ذكاء والان صاروا اكثر
انخراطا ولانه مثل ما قالت الدراسه الاولى
انهم اعينهم تتجه الى الاخبار السلبيه
خوفا على انفسهم وعوائلهم والمستقبل فهم
اكثر تاثر بشيء اللي امامهم بس انا عندي
لك سؤال لئيم شويه وهل هذا السبب انه لما
تصير مشاكل النساء يصير عندهم قدره غريبه
انه يتذكروا الاشياء السلبيه اللي حدثت
عندهم في علاقاتهم ولا لا
ذكرتنا قويه مو اكثر دكتور
بس في السلبيات كل شيء والله في كل شيء ما
تخاف علينا
بس انا اعتقد انه الان بطلت المراه متلقيه
للخبر مترقيه للازمه صارت اكثر حضوره اكثر
انخراطا ولانو احنا دائما بنقول المراه
اكثر ذكاء
وقوه من الرجل وانا اسف اذا كان في بعض
الاشخاص ما يتقبله من عندي هذا الكلمه فهي
دائما ترسم الخطوتين ال ال ال المقبلتين
الاسره في تشعر بالضغط والتوتر قبل ما
يشعر به الرجل وتشعر بالانعكاساته على
نفسها وعلى اسرتها قبل ما يشعر به الاطراف
الاخر
في حال كان هناك وضع سيء واخبار سيئه ولم
يكن قادره على التغيير الوضع ما مدى دق
ذلك نفسه
انا اعتقد انه هذا الامر له علاقه
بالضغوطات المجتمعيه اللي توضع على المراه
واللي هي تعتبر الحلقه الاضعفي مع الاسف
كانت تعتبر الحلقه الاضعف في اي علاقه
موجوده كان ينظر الى المراه على ان هي
المسببه للمشاكل لانه الطرف الاخر كان
يقوم بكل ما يستطيع ان يقوم به فاي تقصير
كان كانت تلام عليه المراه هذا رسب عندها
شعور دائم انه اي خطا يحدث ربما يكون لها
يدفي وهذا اللي خليها دائما تشعر ان هي
اقل في اي علاقه تدخل فيها وربما هذا يفسر
ايضا ليش همم النساء دائما بداوا يعترضوا
ان يتلقوا مقابل اقل من الرجال للقيام
باعمال اكثر من عندهم وهذا اللي بحدث هو
اللي يدخل الفتره الماضيه
تتاثر بالاخبار السيئه نرج- نسمع راي
الشارع ونرجع لك دكتور
[موسيقى]
لقد تاثرا الرجل طبعا لانه الرجل
بحكم عقله تقريبا اما الان بتحكم عاطفتها
اغلب الاوقات يعني ممكن تقرا الخبر يكون
ما له داعي اصلا تمام
وبتتعاطف مع المراه طبعا اكيد لان المراه
عندها شفافيه وحساسه اكثر من الرجل وطبعا
وعاطفيه وهذا هي طبعا دائما المراه هي
بتتفاعل معي كل اي احداث سواء الحزن او
الفرح
[موسيقى]
الست
تتاثر
ممكن نحطها حنان ما بتحب تسمع اخبار سيئه
يعني لانه بصراحه مبلد يعني متعود على
اخبار السيئه مافي اخبار منيحه
[موسيقى]
فش حدا ما بتاثر بالاخبار السيئه الكل
بيتاثر بس الرجل يعني بتوقع انه عنده قدر
على انه يكبه مشاعر شويه يعني مثلا ممكن
انه يكون حزين اكثر من ورا بس مش يعني مش
بسهوله يبكي
[موسيقى]
الشارع المراه او نساء بطبعهم العاطفيه
الحساس هل يتاثرن بكل الاخبار مهما كان
طبيعتها كالمونديال مثلا سياسه يعني احنا
اكثر تاثر منكم بنتائج المونديال
ما اعتقد انه هو الامر الى هذه الدرجه لكن
انا اعتقد انه اهتمام المراه اكثر من
الرجل فاذا اهتمهم بالطعام فهي اكثر
اهتماما واذا اهتم كلاهما بالمونديال فهي
اكثر اهتماما منه
الاشكاليه انه في بعض الاختلافات اللي في
المجتمع فرضها على الرجل والمراه
الضغوطات على الرجل انه يكون شويه يظهر
انه هو صلب ولا يستطيع ان يستطيع ان
يتعامل مع الضغوطات بينما قد تكون المراه
اكثر قدره منه حتى لو كانت ظهرت امام
الاخرين وهي ضعيفه ربما ضعف في تلك الفتره
هو اللي مطلوب اصلا في التعامل مع هذه
الامور في فرق شديد وخلق كبير بين كلمه
القوه وكلمه القسوه وما يعتقد انه لانه
الرجل اقسى من المراه فهو اكثر قوه من
عندها اصلا هي المراه عندها نوع من الذكاء
العاطفيه تتخلص من المشاعر السلبيه اول
باول وتعبر عن اهتمامات اول بين الرجل
ظهرها على شكل قسوه وغضب واذا ويفقد كثيره
اثناء محاولت معالجه المشاكل اللي تعرضت
الدكتور معروف انه الاخبار السيئه مهما
كانت طبيعتها تؤثر على صحتنا نفسيا ماذا
تنصح كخبير نفسي كل الذين يتاثرون بتلك
الاخبار
خلينا اضيف كمان وسعتنا الجسديه كمان بحثت
انه كان في دراسه قبل 18 سنه درست الخصوبه
عند النساء اكتشفت انه لانه النساء
يتعرضوا الى ضغوطات اكثر من الرجال حتى
الخصوبه عندهم مش بس البشره مش بس
للالتهابات الصحيح انه احسن نصيحه انه
ممكن ان احنا نسويها انه جدول الاولويات
اللي عندنا في اشياء ما تستحق انه احنا
كثير نتوتر عليها بضمنها مع كل احترامي
اللي بيحدث الان في المونديال وبعض
الممارسات التي تعتقدي انه هي شويه اوفر
ثم النصيحه الثانيه انه نترك للامر وقته
حتى يمر احنا من حقنا ان احنا نقلق من
الغد لكن يجب ان نعيش اليوم قبل انه نقلق
من الغد صح هذا ما يمنع انه بعض الاشخاص
قد يحتاجوا الى المساعده المجتمعيه
والمساعده النفسيه فاذا احتاج لها الاولى
ان يتوجه لها قبل ما تتدهور الامور تتراكم
المشاكل شكرا جزيلا من الرياض استشاره
نفسي الدكتور اسامه نعيم شكرا جزيلا دكتور